[Music]  I'm obsessed with porks  uh yes people keep sending me recipes of  how they should be prepared to eat  opinions about ports I think that you  know we should try and resist eating  porks I really I really do I think I  think you know they too should have a  place on the planet or the universe so I  think let's all try and not eat pause  thank you thank you  supreme leader snoke isn't the only Star  Wars actor I asked about ports John  boyega gave me the big exclusive I've  been searching for earlier this month at  New York comic-con I need to know  everything that there is about porn so  cute man what if some way to hate sports  [Music]  you  [Music]